le troisième week-end de départ en
vacances arrivent et avec lui ses
milliers d'automobilistes impatient
d'arriver à destination
l'occasion de rappeler aux usagers des
autoroutes quelques conseils le ministre
des transports clément boon s'est rendu
ce jeudi au péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines il me
paraissait important comme les
transports d'insister sur quelques
messages simples mais qui mérite
toujours d'être rappelé que chacun fasse
en responsabilité toutes les petites
vérification on vérifie son véhicule on
prépare son voyage on emporte de l'eau
notamment quand on voyage en famille on
fait une pause toutes les deux heures
une pause d'au moins 20 minutes pour se
reposer que ce soit une vraie pause
réparatrice chacun une part de ce
plaisir des vacances cette
responsabilité collective entre les
mains et au volant donc vraiment
vigilance prudence responsabilité le
ministre des transports a pu y
rencontrer les équipes mobilisées sur la
sécurité routière il a également visité
le centre d'information trafic
objectif mettre un coup de projecteur
sur ces hommes et femmes en jaune sur
les bords des routes au total 31
accidents ont lieu sur le réseau vinci
depuis le 1er janvier faire attention
aux agents de l'état des sociétés
d'autoroutes qui sont souvent avec un
gilet jaune sur le bas côté pour notre
sécurité il faut respecter aussi la leur
et protéger leurs vies nous avons trop
d'accidents on a été meurtri meurtri
cette année dans notre cher puisqu'on a
perdu à nos collaborateurs du district
d'orange sur l'autoroute a9 le 5 avril
dernier et qu'on a un vrai enjeu sur la
sécurité de nos patrouilleurs les anges
gardiens de l'autoroute je pense que
vraiment la prévention ça fait partie
vraiment d'un message qu'on doit répéter
martelé rappelé et il a rappelé
d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt des corridors
de sécurité on sait qu'aujourd'hui il ya
38 % des français qui connaissent cette
règle du corridor de sécurité mais il en
reste encore beaucoup qui doivent
apprendre une visite traditionnelle au
péage emblématique de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines auquel le
nouveau ministre des transports ne
déroge pas une forme de tradition à
laquelle je sacrifie bien volontiers
qu'un ministre des transports fortiori
quand il prend ses fonctions l'été viens
ici parce que c'est un endroit
emblématique
tout français même quand ils ne passent
pas par saint-arnoult même entendent à
la télévision à la radio les points
trafic et au péage de saint-arnoult une
prévention nécessaires pour ce week-end
classé rouge et noir par bison futé sur
les départs en vacances